hallo mein name ist khan meine lieben
freunde ihr seht es bereits im titel
geschrieben ich muss mein minecraft
projekt beenden ich hasse es wenn
youtuber in solchen info videos immer so
zehn stunden um den heißen brei herum
lagern deswegen habe ich direkt die
türen ins haus rein oder wie das heißt
mein pc ist verreckt
windows wie es euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon denken können habe ich davon weder
ein backup gemacht noch habe ich
irgendwas in der cloud gespeichert oder
so ich war einfach naiv und dumm und
dachte mir das passiert mir nicht dieser
fette pc steht die ganze zeit rum ich
bin da nur für die arbeit dran da können
keine viren draufkommen der wird nicht
geklaut er ist unkaputtbar
die ganzen extrem wichtigen sachen wie
beispielsweise meine steuer
prüfungsunterlagen rechnungen generelle
dateien uni dokumente und sonnencremes
das habe ich alles auf meinem macbook
gespeichert um da dann auch in icloud
und weiter und so fort allerdings habe
ich halt nicht an solche sachen wie
meine minecraft welt gedacht wenn ich
spiele nicht minecraft auf meinem
macbook und das hatte ich nur hier drauf
und sowas ist halt alles weg genauso wie
meine hintergrundmusik und sowas aber
das ist leider das einzige was ich von
minecraft mit luca staffel 2 wirklich
noch gespeichert habe ist diese
notiz das ist die weihnachts folge einer
notizen was ich dafür brauchte was ich
bauen wollte und generelle tue das was
ich eigentlich noch so grob vorhatte im
projekt was ich zum glück auch direkt zu
beginn von minecraft mit luca staffel 2
gesichert haben ist der zieht ihr könnt
euch jetzt entweder hier abschreiben
oder ihr gebt mal unter dem video in die
video beschreibung der könnt ihr euch
den dann nämlich raus kopieren und wenn
ihr dann meine ganze modifikation
installiert wie beispielsweise plenio
bei uns et cetera dann werdet ihr die
gleiche welt bekommen wie sie ich
gespielt habe große frage ist nun
allerdings wie gehts bei rita ich könnte
jetzt natürlich einfach meinen zieht
nehmen und den in minecraft einfügen so
dass ich schon mal genau die gleiche
welt habe allerdings ist dann halt das
nächste problem dass ich schon mehr
folge 24 war und ich habe in jeder folge
um die ein bis zwei stunden aufgenommen
das heißt mindestens 40 stunden wird es
dauern um all das was ich bereits gebaut
haben minecraft luca staffel 2 nochmal
neu zu bauen und dann wäre es auch nicht
notwendig weil ich das nicht zusammen
mit euch gebaute habe sondern einfach
alleine und es ist irgendwie dann auch
doof aber
ich werde ich wenn ich direkt schon wenn
ich werden nichtig wenn ich nicht direkt
schon eine neue idee hätte
ich werde euch die neue idee noch nicht
verraten allerdings kann ich euch sagen
dass es anfang märz damit losgehen wird
und es wird auch ein multiplayer
minecraft projekt sei also wenn ihr
weiterhin bock auf minecraft mit mir
luca auf einem kanal ihr habt dann
lasten daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da abonniert meinen kanal und klickt auf
die glocke wenn jetzt nicht schon
gemacht habt in die weitere kommentare
oder tipps habe ich vielleicht mehr welt
doch noch zurückholen kann dann schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare an der
stelle auch noch mal ein riesiges sorry
von mir mein pc hat einfach diesen
partymodus plötzlich aktivierter kamen
rot blau grün
kaputt alles weg ich kann abschließend
einfach nur sagen ein problem ist immer
nur eine dornige chance und das müssen
wir einfach anpacken tut zwar weh wenn
dann bond ran sondern wir müssen jetzt
einfach anpacken müssen jetzt damit
leben nicht ärgern leute einfach nur
wundern fischers fritz frische fische
und schuster bleib bei deinen leisten
ron tutor lag simon basket- und
wer nicht wagt der nicht gewinnt
real talk packt mich natürlich hätte ich
gern weitergemacht aber das projekt ab
märz mit doppelt so geil ich hoffe da
freuen wir uns alle gemeinsam drauf und
da sehen wir uns wieder voll rein und
bis gestern
[Musik]